So let's look at a demo. This is what the example white balance routine looks like in Matlab.
As you can see it's quite short. Matlab is a high level programming language.
It's got a simple syntax and a whole lot of built in math and engineering functions.
So this whole routine can be written in just 6 lines of code.
Now the way this is written out, currently this function runs entirely on a CPU.
And so next what we're going to do is use the Matlab profiler
to identify sections of this code that might be candidates to run on GPU to improve performance.
So we run the profiler and it indicates that this last line is by far the most time consuming.
This line of code is applying an operation to each color channel across every pixel on the image.
Such an operation could be sped up when executed on a GPU.
This is clearly a good candidate for parallel computing.
So before using the GPU, let's first measure how long it takes to execute the white balance function
on the CPU, using the tick and tock commands.
Notice that it takes approximately 0.124 seconds to execute the code entirely on the CPU.
Now to utilize the GPU for executing that last line of code, there's a couple of options.
One thing that we could do is simply transfer the image data
to the GPU memory using the GPU array command.
And that's what we're doing here on line 14 of this slightly modified white balance routine.
Whenever a GPU is passed as input to the most common core Matlab functions,
as in this last line of code, then those computations will automatically be executed on the GPU.
So, here by adding just that single line of code,
notice that the time it takes to execute the white balance function
went down from 0.124 seconds to 0.026 seconds.
So that's a big speed up, especially for a single line of code.
So the second approach to using the GPU for computing within Matlab
is to use the Matlab interface to invoke custom Cuda kernels.
Here's a Cuda kernel that performs the same operation that was causing
that original bottleneck in the white balance routine.
And in this Matlab function, that Cuda kernel is being used
to speed up the execution time instead of using GPU array.
So the first 12 lines of code are the same as in the original white balance routine.
Then, however, Matlab loads the kernel and sets up the threading parameters,
Creates data on the GPU, and finally invokes the kernel using f eval.
And now notice that the white balance routine executes in .022 seconds using the Cuda kernel.
So the application executes faster but we should still verify that our Cuda does what its supposed to do.
So we need ask the question, do the results from the GPU
match the results that we were getting on the CPU?
And you can check that the outputs match, using this simple script
which computes the norm of the difference between outputs.
So a norm equal to 0, signifies that the 2 outputs are the same.
After running verified script, we can see that the 2 outputs are the same, and there we go.
So, in summary, Matlab is a nice high-level language.
It is used heavily by scientists and engineers all over the world
for all kinds of applications, and its a great way to quickly design
and test algorithms that perform computations on a GPU, either by using the gpuArray command,
or by using an interface directly to CUDA kernels.
Furthermore, existing CUDA kernels can be quickly and easily tested inside Matlab.
It makes a great harness for developing an exploring and testing CUDA kernels.
And that's Matlab.